sí
hola buenos días a todos
buenos dias christine bienvenidos todos
gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana
pues vamos a comenzar
el tema de hoy es estrategias para
motivar a los alumnos que es un tema
súper importante para para todos yo creo
que es una parte esencial no en nuestra
práctica educativa para poder realmente
encauzar a nuestros alumnos y motivarlos
no para que siempre den el mejor de sus
esfuerzos
antes que nada gracias por venir gracias
por su compromiso por su esfuerzo no por
el apoyo que le dan a los alumnos a
través de esta excelente plataforma
entonces queremos no recalcar las que
estamos aquí para apoyarlos no para
ayudarlos para lo que ustedes necesitan
con el objetivo de maximizar los
resultados de todos nuestros alumnos en
méjico
les quiero compartir el enlace de esta
presentación para que la puedan bajar a
sus dispositivos si tienen ahorita
acceso a su computador pueden anotar
este enlace en una ventana y guardarlo
en su en su disco duro si no tienen
ahorita acceso a un dispositivo no se
preocupen tomen una foto con su teléfono
etcétera y más adelante la pueden bajar
ya ya cuando tengan acceso a su
computador no entonces esto queda para
ustedes para que puedan hacer referencia
más adelante a esta presentación así que
les voy a dar unos unos segunditos para
que lo puedan tomar la foto o ingresar
es jeje punto eje diagonal
d minúscula t minúscula 4 c minúscula y
de minúsculas se los estoy poniendo
también
a veces me deja ponerlo en el en el chat
este es el enlace
je je je je
diagonal d minúscula t 4 c b
ok
pues vamos a
no me deja meterlo en la presentación
pero bueno no no importa el les doy unos
unos segunditos para que puedan copiarlo
tomar una foto cuidado con minúsculas
porque si no no van a poder entrar
y bueno vamos a comenzar
espero todos puedan hayan podido bajarla
y antes que nada quiero invitarlos a que
nos hagan todas sus sugerencias todas
sus preguntas a través del chat del
webinar yo creo que es muy importante
para el éxito de cualquier capacitación
de cualquier entrenamiento de cualquier
webinar la participación de ustedes
entonces a través del chat háganos
llegar sus preguntas su sugerencia sus
experiencias sobre todo y más en este
tema que estamos aquí vamos a hablar de
motivación porque creo que la
experiencia de ustedes y las estrategias
que ustedes han utilizado realmente
pueden servir a otros no nos pueden
servir a todos no para poder aprender
más y para poder utilizar nuevas formas
entonces yo creo que es súper importante
no antes que cualquier proyecto yo creo
que en cualquier proyecto que iniciamos
tanto personal como académico es
importante desarrollar un plan o un plan
para motivar en este caso a nuestros
alumnos como planeamos no seguir
el progreso de nuestros alumnos como
planeamos celebrar sus logros celebrar
no su esfuerzo cómo podemos motivarlos
no a que sigan perseverando a que no se
den por vencidos a que tengan una
mentalidad de éxito más que una
mentalidad de fracaso no y cómo vamos a
poder evaluar el desempeño y los
esfuerzos de los alumnos dentro de esta
plataforma de canacar
y les voy a compartir un vídeo se los
voy a poner en español así que me un un
segundito para poder poner los títulos
en español pero este vídeo me encanta
porque realmente refleja a mucho no lo
que nosotros hacemos en clase no de
diferentes maneras cómo motivamos
nosotros a nuestros alumnos
y yo creo que es muy cierto esto que
plantea este vídeo se los voy a
compartir
espero les les gusta a mí me encanta
[Música]
voy a mostrar el cyber
quieto
[Música]
by tim payne
no podéis que ver edificios
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
bueno
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tu amigo y volver a china
[Aplausos]
[Música]
yoo
y bueno considero esta parte o no este
vídeo muy importante y como les comento
me encanta porque es muy cierto no todos
podemos aprender algo siempre no a
cualquier edad en cualquier momento en
cualquier estado de nuestras vidas
y más ustedes no me dejarán mentir digo
yo al igual que ustedes he sido maestra
de matemáticas y de ciencias por durante
muchos años y sabemos no de la
frustración de algunos de nuestros
alumnos en especial en estas materias
que sienten lo que sienten que no pueden
que sienten que no nacieron para
matemáticas que no nacieron para
ciencias y es un luchar siempre nosotros
como docentes con estos prejuicios que
ya está en nuestros alumnos no desde que
la materia es difícil de que de que les
cuesta trabajo de que ellos no nacieron
para aprender matemáticas sus ciencias
y este vídeo justamente nos dice lo
contrario no yo creo que es tan
importante fomentar a nuestros alumnos
una mentalidad de éxito y parte de ese
proceso es definitivamente el
reconocerlos no es reconocer su energía
su esfuerzo su motivación aunque
fracasen porque a veces fracasan no y
simplemente tienen que aprender que es
un paso en un paso más para el éxito un
paso más para seguir avanzando entonces
sabemos todos que hay dos tipos de
motivación es lo que viene siendo la
motivación intrínseca lo que es ya parte
del del alumno que viene ya del alumno
que yo creo que es muy difícil de lograr
no hay más nuevamente en nuestras
materias no que el alumno encuentre
maneras de motivarse a sí mismo no
y yo creo que es muy importante porque
es cuando realmente el alumno se hace
responsable de su aprendizaje no
necesita de otros para motivarlo y bueno
este es el punto ideal lo que toma esto
queremos alcanzar cómo podemos lograr
esto no entonces ahí hay varias
estrategias que nos sugieren los
especialistas en educación en psicología
etcétera por ejemplo darle a los alumnos
una sensación como de control una
sensación en donde ellos sientan que que
pueden digamos tener cierto control
dentro de clases no que a lo mejor
pueden decidir qué ejercicios hacer qué
parte necesitan ellos repasar porque a
lo mejor nuestros alumnos no todos son
iguales no no todos están en la misma
situación no todos tienen las mismas
dudas los darles a ellos esa sensación
de que pueden decidir que necesitan
practicar quiénes en que necesitan
enfocarse para seguir mejorando eso los
motiva mucho y definitivamente lo
podemos lograr a través de la
y crear un entorno también libre de
amenazas no donde el alumno se sienta
confiado yo creo que también gran parte
de esta frustración de este miedo a la
materia y yo creo que ustedes también
como maestros de matemáticas y de
ciencia lo han experimentado que el
alumno siente la amenaza o el miedo de
preguntar por qué se siente expuesto no
hay a veces pues tiene dudas etcétera y
esto se siente que lo van a juzgar que
lo van a ver feo que lo van a tachar de
tonto etcétera entonces cuando existe el
salón de clase ese ambiente relajado
donde exista realmente un ambiente
positivo que el alumno sienta que tiene
la confianza de preguntar desde hace de
tener sus dudas de acercarse al maestro
de acercarse a tu compañero etcétera en
esa medida
definitivamente el ambiente en clase
pues cambia no entonces esa parte es muy
importante y ofrecer experiencias
diferentes también a veces nos cuesta
trabajo como docentes y por qué porque
estamos
cargados de chamba a veces tenemos
demasiado trabajo sin embargo es
importante poder encontrar y exponer a
los alumnos a diferentes experiencias no
ya sea dentro del salón como fuera del
salón o sea un paseo fuera de la escuela
etcétera pero también hasta dentro de la
escuela por ejemplo lo que tiene es el
dow campeonato nos ofrece una nueva
experiencia no nos ofrece una nueva
posibilidad de enfrentar a nuestros
alumnos a un reto diferente divertido
etcétera
y todo eso motiva a los alumnos no lo
saca de la rutina etcétera promover la
competencia positiva también es un punto
muy importante no vamos a hablar un
poquito más de esto promover el
aprendizaje activo yo creo que ya
también como docentes en este siglo 21
degusta lleno de retos no sólo para
nuestros alumnos no sino también para
nosotros no tenemos una serie de retos
porque en nuestras manos está educar a
estos alumnos del siglo 21
que hoy día están en nuestros salones de
clase estudiando con nosotros y van al
día de mañana a estudiar carreras que
probablemente hoy me existan porque en
uno está cambiando muy rápidamente las
necesidades del mundo global también
están cambiando constantemente entonces
son nuestros alumnos necesitan aprender
habilidades no habilidades para poder
enfrentar con éxito todos los retos que
plantea este este siglo y el que viene
entonces promover el aprendizaje activo
promover la colaboración promover la
comunicación son habilidades que los
alumnos definitivamente van a utilizar y
les van a ser de gran utilidad no para
para tener éxito no solamente en su vida
académica sino en su vida personal y
promover el trabajo colaborativo yo creo
que esta es una de las habilidades que
más está necesitando en este siglo hubo
una encuesta que se hizo hacia
a través del economista en la revista
está del economista a varios profesores
ya varios líderes de empresas etcétera
en donde se les preguntaba cuáles eran
las habilidades que los alumnos deben
desarrollar para poder tener éxito
en la vida laboral en este siglo y una
de estas habilidades en la que todos
hablaron es el trabajo colaborativo
enseñar a nuestros alumnos a trabajar
con otros no a comunicarse con otros y
yo creo que en la medida que nosotros lo
fomentamos también en nuestro salón de
clases no solamente estamos
desarrollando en ellos estabilidad sino
también motivando los porque siempre la
verdad el trabajo en equipo motiva no
hace un logro común etcétera
nuevamente los quiero invitar a qué
nos hagan llegar sus preguntas sus
comentarios sus sugerencias a través del
chat queremos saludar a todos los que
están aquí desde sinaloa guadalajara
this means am
de verdad que les agradecemos a todos el
plantel al doctor eduardo macías o sea
les agradecemos del plantel doctor
eduardo macías perdón
desde la facultad de medicina gracias a
todos por estar aquí presentes
nuevamente los invitamos maestros por
favor sus comentarios sugerencias sus
experiencias es lo que más enriquece
esta capacitación así que
cuenten los cuéntenos que están haciendo
qué hacen ustedes para para motivar a
sus alumnos no yo creo que las
experiencias ahorita en el salón de
clases son las que más pueden enriquecer
y brindarnos nuevas ideas a otros
docentes
tijuana también muchas gracias por estar
aquí y bienvenidos y vamos a continuar
yo creo que otra parte importantísima no
te de motivar a nuestros alumnos es
establecer objetivos claros y eso bueno
nos pasa en en cualquier situación no
para nosotros comenzar un proyecto es
básico poder
tener claro no hacia dónde vamos que
queremos los estudiantes quieren y
necesitan saber qué se espera de ellos
para mantenerse motivados y para estar
enfocados en un objetivo al principio
del año debemos establecer nuestros
objetivos claros nuestras reglas
nuestras expectativas para que los
estudiantes no se sientan confundidos y
tengan claras no cuáles son sus metas
para trabajar igual al inicio de
cualquier proyecto no ahorita estamos
trabajando con campeonato entonces es
importante que los alumnos se entiendan
cuáles son sus objetivos qué es lo que
ellos necesitan lograr y trabajar para
alcanzar el éxito no de manera que no
generemos después frustración porque yo
creo que esta es la parte más importante
cuando el alumno no tiene claro sus
objetivos es cuando puede darse la
frustración cuando puede aparecer la
desmotivación porque no lo se logró el
objetivo porque simplemente no se tenían
claros no entonces esta parte es muy
importante
los alumnos
cuando están
motivados ellos siempre no se sienten
parte de una comunidad y es muy
importante esto como hablamos del
trabajo colaborativo de tener los
objetivos claros es ahí cuando pueden
ellos trabajar por un objetivo común no
a trabajar en equipo para lograr algo es
una parte muy importante de la
motivación y hay que establecer
objetivos no solamente individuales sino
también grupales no objetivos que los
alumnos puedan cuantificar puedan medir
puedan ver no puedan realmente palpar y
sobre todo nuestros objetivos siempre
deben ser realistas no siempre es por
eso que es muy importante que conozcamos
a nuestros alumnos para que realmente
podamos establecer objetivos que sean
realistas no porque nuevamente si no es
así podemos generar mucha frustración no
en lugar de motivarlos los podemos
a frustrarlo y también a implementar un
proyecto no un programa de recompensas
de incentivos para aquellos alumnos que
van alcanzando sus objetivos
comentarios hasta acá preguntas
buenos días desde perú qué gusto
tenerlos acá
plantel naucalpan bienvenidos registrada
nos comenta enseñarse y apoyarse entre
ellos resulta muy motivador
tener aquí un excelente punto y de hecho
vamos a hablar de esa parte porque lo
que nos comenta la maestra estrada es
muy cierto yo creo que nada motiva más a
un alumno que sentirse que él también
puede compartir puede enseñar a otros
compañeros y además entre compañeros
entienden muy bien esta es una técnica
excelente la verdad porque sin motivan a
otros alumnos no solamente enseñar a los
otros también los motiva a aprender
muchas gracias doctora maestra estrada
por su participación tratar de hacer que
confíen en ellos no en ellos mismos y en
varias ocasiones me ha dado gusto que
ofrezcan ayuda a sus compañeros esta
parte es es muy importante vamos a
profundizar un poquito más en esta parte
los invitamos a que sigan comentando
sigan dándonos sus estrategias sus ideas
es muy importante su participación y su
experiencia en este en este
entrenamiento y bueno parte de la
motivación extrínseca nos ha que podemos
hacer de manera extreme se que a
nosotros como docentes para motivarlos
pues podemos ofrecer recompensas y
definitivamente siempre con el objetivo
de reconocer sus esfuerzos sus logros
entonces podemos generar por ejemplo a
certificados personalizados que pueden
ser un diploma impreso por nosotros
mismos en donde escribamos el nombre del
alumno en donde él lo entreguemos a lo
mejor en una ceremonia puede ser dentro
del mismo salón de clases al final de la
semana o bien dentro del plantel a lo
mejor una semana en las si tienen alguna
ceremonia de la bandera alguna ceremonia
cada semana en donde se puedan reconocer
dentro de la escuela los alumnos que han
alcanzado a sus objetivos
recuerden que en campeonato no tenemos
objetivos muy claros no tenemos el
objetivo de asignar tres recursos
mínimos a cada alumno a cada uno de
nuestros alumnos que está participando
en campeonato
entonces si estos alumnos y nuestros
alumnos cumplan con estos objetivos hay
que reconocerlos hay que llamarlos al
frente darles un aplauso y recuerden que
para él para tener éxito dentro del
campeonato necesitamos la participación
del 100% de nuestros alumnos es por eso
que es muy importante motivarlos para
que sigan trabajando
el profesor antonio cisneros nos comenta
motivarlos es una función imprescindible
del maestro narrar una historia de vida
podría ser un motivador excelente no me
parece una no una idea maravillosa no
porque los más alumnos también aprenden
de nosotros esta parte que comenta el
maestro antonio cisneros es vital los
alumnos nosotros somos su ejemplo cuando
nosotros les contamos o compartimos con
nuestros alumnos historias nuestras
también de frustración también de note
en donde hemos sido pues también
confrontados no hay dificultades
etcétera yo creo que eso los motiva
porque se sienten de alguna manera
identificados con nosotros
la profesora areal y montserrat
le dice motivando conociendo exactamente
lo que se enseña por ejemplo el uso de
la plataforma yo creo que también esto
es un punto importante no nosotros como
maestros somos su guía no somos
a quienes vamos también a guiarlos
dentro de este proceso de
enseñanza-aprendizaje entonces
conociendo la plataforma también
teniendo este punto de vista del alumno
cómo perciben nuestros alumnos las
platas la plataforma de cada karem y
cuáles son las dificultades que pueden
tener cómo van a percibir ellos los
ejercicios los vídeos es cierto no la
maestra muchas gracias por su
participación en este punto es muy
importante para motivarlos y para
enseñar lo necesitamos nosotros primero
conocer bien
qué es lo que estamos dándoles qué
herramientas les estamos proporcionando
otra idea también para motivar a
nuestros alumnos es por ejemplo colocar
un tablero de anuncios en nuestro salón
de clases donde podamos celebrar los
avances logrados no podemos elegir qué
es lo que queremos celebrar a la mejor
pueden ser el número de tareas
completadas la cantidad de tiempo que se
que pasaron los alumnos en la plataforma
en las habilidades que practicaron el
número de habilidades que llegaron a
dominar o el número de medallas que
ganaron o el número de ejercicios que
contestaron en una semana no eso ya ya
va siendo no depende ya de cada profesor
qué es lo que quiere celebrar y puedes
dar medallas puedes no dar este no sea
algún algo significativo algún símbolo
alguna algún papelito que implique una
medalla etcétera y hacer un tablero en
donde los alumnos puedan ir viendo su
progreso donde vean reflejado su nombre
donde se les reconozcan a cuál está
haciendo su esfuerzo que están que están
realmente logrando los objetivos
etcétera no existe es una manera
pero también muy sencilla que no cuesta
y donde los alumnos realmente se sienten
motivados y están viendo reflejados en
algún lugar o sea de una manera muy
visual de poder reconocer sus esfuerzos
la maestra salgado no jacob a salgado no
motivarlos a seguir sus sueños es súper
importante no ir nuestros alumnos están
cargados de sueños no llegan a nuestras
escuelas a nuestros salones de clase con
muchos sueños no a cuestas que a veces
ven frustrados porque sienten que no
pueden no entonces y vamos a hablar
también esto de la mentalidad de
crecimiento tan importante entonces
es muy cierto no a motivarlos a que
pueden lograr los bienvenidos con la leb
de calco
y aunque hoy vamos a ver qué otra manera
no podemos motivarlos y bueno
organizándoles no algo algo sencillo una
fiesta con 10 pizzas con donas con
helado con dulces con no sé nosotros yo
creo que también parte importante de
este programa de motivación es conocer a
nuestros alumnos no saber cómo son
quiénes son que los motiva que les gusta
y ya con base en eso podemos realmente
recompre compensarlos reconocerlos de
una mejor manera no entonces podemos
organizar les no algo algo que ellos
en los motive los alegres se sientan
reconocidos y además en este programa en
este proyecto de de motivación estamos
además conectándonos con nuestros
alumnos los alumnos al sentirse
reconocidos al sentirse valorados de
verdad que el ambiente en el salón de
clases cambia al 100% no entonces hay
una conexión que se hace muy especial
con el maestro porque los alumnos es lo
que buscan ser reconocido por el maestro
entonces esta conexión él realmente
además de motivarlos cambian o cambia el
ambiente en el salón es más positivo no
el alumno está más enfocado al logro al
objetivo y en general es un ganar-ganar
tanto para el alumno como para el
maestro
y bueno otra
parte importante no viene siendo por
ejemplo fomentar la competencia sana no
podemos llevar una competencia no entre
el mejor entre clases no solamente entre
los alumnos de nuestra clase pero la
mejor entre sí estamos trabajando con
tres primeros de secundaria pues
fomentar la una competencia sana entre
los tres grupos a ver qué clase cumple
primero a la mejor sus objetivos no
quien en dentro del campeonato termina
su primer sus tres actividades etcétera
antes no que que otros pueden hacer
boletos no que los alumnos que terminan
primero a lo mejor estas tres
actividades los primeros de cinco
alumnos o diez alumnos que terminen
primero
sus tres actividades darles algún boleto
que más adelante puedan intercambiar no
por un lápiz por un sticker por algo que
los alumnos no consideren como un
reconocimiento y siempre al final de la
semana reconocer el esfuerzo no tenemos
dentro del campeonato nuestro trato
tablero no del progreso de donde podemos
ver no el el logro de nuestros alumnos y
cómo van alcanzando sus metas y este
tablero ya les reconoce de por si este
esfuerzo no ya cuando llegan al 100% de
su objetivo no hay ustedes saben que hay
premios digitales creados especialmente
para campeonato en donde los alumnos se
sienten motivados no ustedes también al
participar en campeonatos reciben un kit
para con diferentes lápices etcétera
premios que también pueden utilizar para
motivar a sus alumnos
tenemos acá algunos comentarios
es una pregunta de la maestra maría de
la luz roja me registre desde el módulo
a1 debo registrarme para cada módulo no
no necesita registrarse usted debe de
estar recibiendo correos en donde se les
informa de cada web y nar
nones y ya se registran una ocasión no
necesitan registrarse una segunda el
profesor pedro
efe nos comenta llevarlos más allá de lo
que pueden visualizar desde su contenido
no a veces como personas en general
dejamos de crecer porque sentimos que
dentro de nuestro contexto estamos bien
es muy cierto esto
y la verdad es que dentro de nuestra
cultura muchas veces
no sé no nos educan para tener éxito no
entonces cuando tenemos problemas cuando
nos enfrentamos a fracasos etcétera
automáticamente la mentalidad de
nuestros jóvenes se enfoca en el fracaso
no en sus logros no nos quedamos muchas
veces es cierto en nuestra zona de
confort como como comenta el maestro
pedro ve lo que otros están logrando
permite abrir el panorama de
posibilidades y establecer metas más
ambiciosos muy cierto muchas gracias
maestro por por ésta
no por este comentario por esta
reflexión la maestra lilia estrada los
míos llegan cada sesión muy motivados
preguntando por el campeonato y viendo
cuántas tareas tienen esto es muy cierto
no lo finalmente son jóvenes que al
sentirse reconocidos nuevamente no y
valorados y escuchados automáticamente
su enfoque a la materia cambia se
sienten motivados y les gusta la materia
definitivamente para mi campeonato fue
una idea excelente para comenzar el año
con el pie derecho no porque no sé es un
programa grupo padre que pone al alumno
en el centro del aprendizaje estamos
enfocados en ellos no nos pone a
nosotros como docentes en el centro no
sino a ellos y esa parte es muy
importante
seguimos y bueno a otra manera también
de poder motivar a nuestros alumnos es
hacer que ellos hagan un seguimiento de
su propio avance podemos a lo mejor
poner un póster en nuestra en nuestra
clase no en donde podamos poner
diferentes este no categorías no sea
aquellos alumnos que ya lograron
alcanzar la medalla de agujero negro o
aquellos alumnos que ya están en la
medalla luna o aquellos alumnos que
tienen no sean lo que que la
perseverancia o aquellos alumnos no que
han colaborado con otros nosotros
nuevamente conociendo a nuestros alumnos
sabemos qué categorías poner y podemos
poner no una cartulina con no a aquellos
alumnos de que ya ganaron estas medallas
que son perseverantes etcétera y
motivarlos a que ellos mismos cuando
sientan lo que realmente merecen estar
en esta cartulina se levantan de su
lugar y vayan y anoten su nombre en esa
cartulina en esta categoría
y esto es súper importante que ellos
ellos no necesiten ser reconocidos por
nosotros que automáticamente yo sientan
yo me merezco estar en esa cartulina yo
me merezco estar en este póster no en es
porque me lo gané porque soy
perseverante porque ya me gané esta
medalla porque he trabajado tanto tiempo
porque he cumplido con todas mis mis
asignaturas de cada semana
entonces ya nosotros dependiendo de
nuestros alumnos sabremos qué categorías
utilizar pero es otra cosa que no cuesta
no podemos poner nada más tres tres tres
cuatro cinco cartulinas las que ustedes
consideren y motivarlos a que ellos se
levanten de su lugar y vayan ya noten su
nombre en cada póster y al final de la
semana reconocer estos alumnos y
felicidades a estos alumnos que están en
este post el que se ha notado en esta
categoría y eso es muy lindo no porque
les estamos poniendo en sus manos no el
reconocerse a sí mismos y esta parte es
súper importante
otra cosa y ya no los comento a una
maestra dentro de este webinar fomentar
la asesoría entre compañeros esto no
solamente motiva a los alumnos
no que quieren compartir lo que están
entendiendo lo que saben sino también
motiva a los alumnos que tienen
problemas no que se sientan atorados en
algún concepto etcétera porque además la
verdad es que la comunicación entre
ellos muchas veces fluyen mejor muchas
veces entre ellos se entienden mejor no
por el lenguaje que usan por porque son
amigos etcétera entonces fomentar esto
la verdad es muy gratificante una manera
que pueden hacerlo no para que no sea la
mejor tan obvio para que no se sientan
lo mejor los alumnos como que tienen que
estar buscando quién los quiere ayudar
pueden poner una cartulina en su salón
de clases también en donde pongan el
nombre o sea poner una tres columnas una
columna en donde los alumnos que
necesitan ayuda lleguen a anotarse ahí
otra columna nos diga qué concepto
necesitas en qué concepto necesitas
ayuda no qué es lo que necesitas que te
expliquen y la tercera columna el alumno
que quiere explicarle no entonces los
alumnos pueden tener también la libertad
levantarse y escribir en el poste lo que
soy no sé no juanita pérez y quiero
practicar necesito entender orden de
operaciones y a la mejor edad otro amigo
y pone en la tercera columna soy a
susanita gonzález yo te puedo ayudar y
entonces eso abre el espacio también a
todos los los alumnos para que tengan
esa libertad de dirigirse a este espacio
entender entre ellos se arreglasen o se
organizan para recibir la ayuda de otro
compañero no me parece una buena idea
pero sí es importante fomentar la
asesoría entre ellos no la el
aprendizaje entre ellos
y bueno una parte muy importante dentro
del campeonato y ya lo hemos comentado
en otros webinars no en otros
entrenamientos es la importancia de
fomentar una mentalidad de crecimiento y
bueno gana academy y nos puso o no nos
nos otorga digamos la posibilidad de
hacer esto
porque tiene un programa para fomentar
la mente la de crecimiento muy
importante muy padre la verdad no sé si
ya empezaron a asignar estas actividades
pero verdaderamente digo yo las he
estado revisando me encantan porque
realmente fomentan en el alumno el
cambio de este chip no que tenemos no
desde el fracaso del no del no orientada
al no puedo cambiar el chip por una
mentalidad de éxito no icann academy ha
trabajado muy de cerca con converters
con es que su centro de investigación de
la universidad de stanford
que ayuda en este trabajo con estas
actividades que ayudan a los educadores
a aplicar estrategias basadas en
estudios en evidencia que ellos han
recolectado con el objetivo de alcanzar
excelencia académica y equidad entonces
estas no son actividades la verdad
sacadas de la manga son actividades que
se han trabajado mucho se han estudiado
mucho para que realmente puedan lograr
el objetivo
entonces estas actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento y ahorita vamos a entrar
a plataforma les quiero enseñar cómo las
asignamos estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento ayudan a que
los alumnos desarrollen una mentalidad
de aprendizaje en las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento como les digo
son actividades desarrolladas por este
centro de estudios de stanford y a
través a partir de las investigaciones
de carol dweck y aquí lo que lo que lo
que promueven digamos es que fomentar
una mentalidad para aprender no una
mentalidad de crecimiento versus una
mentalidad fija en una mentalidad fija
el alumno piensa por ejemplo y esto lo
tenemos o sea lo vemos muchos nuestros
salones de clase no que el alumno dice
no yo no nací para matemáticas no yo
siempre he sido malísimo para
matemáticas o para ciencias etcétera no
entonces ya traen esta mentalidad fija
piensan que su cerebro no da más porque
hacen así porque así porque así soy
a mí no se me da esto no entonces esto
mentales esta mentalidad de que su mente
su mente su cerebro puede crecer puede
desarrollarse que los errores son una
oportunidad de aprendizaje que los
errores al contrario no pueden ayudarnos
a superar la frustración estas
actividades también ayudan a promover en
los alumnos el que ellos mismos
conociendo sus habilidades puedan
desarrollar estrategias de aprendizaje
propios para ellos y nuevamente es
cuando ponemos al alumno como en el
centro del aprendizaje y que el alumno
sea capaz de conocerse de aprender de
conocer cuál es la mejor manera en que
el aprender y desarrollar sus
estrategias no para aprender mejor crear
metas mentalizarse por el éxito y aquí
el crear metas nosotros podemos crear
nuestras metas como profesores pero
también cada alumno conociéndose porque
sabemos que hay una gran diferencia
entre nuestros alumnos y cada uno debe
crear también sus propias metas para
para no asustarse no porque no podemos
comparar un alumno que es muy exitoso en
matemáticas que todo lo entiende
rapidísimo que le encanta con un alumno
que tiene dificultades no están los
conceptos más básicos entonces tenemos
que entender también que cada uno de
ellos va a crear sus propias metas
también tenemos mentalidades para
enfrentarse a lo inesperado que son
actividades básicamente para
bachillerato y un sentido de pertenencia
no entonces estos son estas actividades
no tienen nada que ver ni con
matemáticas ni con ciencias no son
actividades en donde son testimoniales
vídeos actividades muy diferentes en
donde están creadas de manera que puedan
aplicarse tanto primaria como secundaria
como bachillerato no y que van
acompañando al maestro para ir
fomentando esta mentalidad de
crecimiento en sus alumnos entonces
khan academy lo que hizo fue crear un
curriculum dirigido especialmente para
los alumnos de primaria para los alumnos
de secundaria y de bachillerato también
se incluyeron testimonios de otros
estudiantes vídeos para explicar cómo
funciona el cerebro no para que los
alumnos puedan realmente entender no
como cómo trabaja nuestro cerebro no y
que el cerebro tiene la posibilidad de
crecer de desarrollarse y el porqué la
importancia de establecer metas y de y
de cambiar es elche ese chip no que
tenemos de fracaso no
los invitamos a que sigan comentándonos
no sé si ustedes algunos de ustedes ya
comenzó a utilizar estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento si ya las
comenzaron a enviar digamos no a asignar
a sus alumnos cuenten los de verdad que
es súper importante ver cuál es la
reacción de los alumnos si ustedes han
notado algún cambio de actitud algún
algún comentario que les hayan hecho sus
alumnos al respecto de estas actividades
es bien importante no que que compartan
con nosotros porque finalmente esto nos
va a ayudar también aquí en méxico a
saber cuál es el impacto de estas
actividades no entonces compartan con
nosotros lo que cuál es su experiencia
en lo cuáles son sus
sus comentarios acerca de estas
actividades
entonces los invitamos a que a través de
esta plataforma en este webinar aquí en
el chat oa través de las redes sociales
con el hashtag del campeonato nos
compartan cuéntenos qué no cuáles los
comentarios las olas
la actitud de los alumnos ante estas
actividades cuál es el impacto de estas
actividades creo que a todos a todos los
que estamos participando en un
campeonato no sería de muchísima
utilidad no poder este conocer cuál es
su opinión
sobre todo su experiencia con estas
actividades la mentalidad de crecimiento
es como comentábamos la creencia de que
tu cerebro puede desarrollarse en tu
cerebro puede dar más que tu
inteligencia crece a medida que tú vas
esforzándote a medida que tú vas siendo
perseverante no y no te quedas atorado
en esos frank en esos fracasos o en esos
errores la mentalidad del no puedo no
cambiar ese chip del no puedo y seguir
trabajando no hasta que logras el éxito
no entonces
y esto nos va a ayudar a ir
desarrollando las estrategias adecuadas
para aprenderlo de una mejor manera una
mentalidad de crecimiento se centra en
el proceso del aprendizaje no sé
aquí no importa tanto el resultado
esperado porque en la medida en que
trabajamos todos resultados se puede
convertir en un éxito en una victoria
que es una mentalidad fija lo cual es lo
opuesto la mentalidad fija es la
creencia de que como les comentaba no
así se hacen así este es mi cerebro esto
es lo que puedo dar
estas son mis limitaciones no entonces
eso finalmente limita a nuestros alumnos
no el hecho de que puedan que creen o
que ellos no pueden desarrollar su
cerebro que no son capaces de hacer o de
entender algo eso nos va a llevar
nuevamente al creerse el que nunca lo
van a conseguir
aquí hablamos de un profesor hablo de
los sueños y yo creo que cuando nosotros
motivamos en los alumnos esta mentalidad
de crecimiento no hay sueño que no pueda
ser logrado y yo creo que es muy
importante nuestros alumnos fomentar
esto no al hablar de sus sueños
es también cambiarles este chip de que
los puedan lograr a través del esfuerzo
no importan los fracasos no importan las
veces que fallamos siempre se puede
lograr el éxito si trabajamos con
perseverancia en la mentalidad fija se
centra en el resultado y punto y
solamente tienen dos opciones éxito o
fracaso versus la mentalidad de
crecimiento que es se enfoca no en el
resultado no sino en el proceso no para
para lograr la victoria
la maestra dice martínez nos comenta yo
les asignó tres cada semana excelente y
me encantaría maestra que nos comentará
cuál ha sido el impacto en los alumnos
que le comentan al hacer estas
actividades que dicen cómo los ve cómo
los sientes así siente que están
teniendo algún efecto llevamos pocas
semanas de campeonato pero quizá ya
podemos ver algún cambio en su actitud
no junta éstas recuerden que estas
actividades deben asignarse junto con
las actividades de matemáticas no está
bien hecho maestra martínez porque son
las tres actividades que como mínimo que
debemos asignar dentro del contenido de
nuestro curso y a la vez tenemos que ir
asignando también estas a actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento la maestra
maría de la luz rojas en mi grupo los
alumnos están emocionados de las
gratificaciones virtuales por cada
avance en sus lecciones de khan academy
esta parte es muy importante
el maestro eric coronado saludos soy
profesor
de cetys número 76 aún no implementó las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
pero sin duda hablaré hoy me encanta la
actitud profesor y nos encantaría
también conocer su experiencia cuáles
son los comentarios cuáles son los
resultados también no nuevamente si
tienen twitter si tienen facebook
pongan tomen una foto de sus alumnos
compartan con ellos muchos de sus
alumnos tienen real redes sociales esa
es otra manera de motivarlos al verse a
la mejor en twitter una foto de la lo
mejor del del tablero de la plataforma y
decir mis alumnos de tal grupo lograron
el 100 por ciento alcanzar un tal nivel
y poner el hashtag siempre de campeonato
no poner el este también a khan academy
etcétera todo eso los motiva también no
porque se sientan reconocidos y ya no
sólo dentro de su comunidad no de su
escuela de su plantel sino también
afuera no con no se la haya ahora sí que
en el mundo real en el mundo de allá
afuera entonces otra manera también de
reconocerlos no
es el maestro fernando carrillo dicen
khan academy
la teoría y el salón de clases explicó
la práctica con ejercicios perfecto no
está excelente también acuérdese que
podemos asignar no solamente ejercicios
también vídeos también artículos o día
ya la plataforma nos ofrece a mí me
encanta como la diseñaron ahora entonces
puedes hasta asignar un examen de unidad
no puedes asignar pequeñas evaluaciones
etcétera de manera que vayan de la mano
con lo que nosotros vamos dando en clase
y definitivamente sino como lo comenta
también la maestra eugenia no nos va
todas estas actividades y esta
plataforma ayuda no a que los alumnos se
vayan adaptando mejor al cambio
definitivamente vamos a seguir y bueno
algunas ideas erróneas sobre mentalidad
de crecimiento no
la mentalidad de crecimiento no no es
así como una característica genética un
radio genético no es de que yo nací con
una mentalidad de crecimiento y tú
naciste con una mentalidad fija no no no
es no es esto no no no es así no ni
tampoco es un estado esto es una algo
que nosotros desarrollamos no que le
damos esta herramienta a nuestros
alumnos con el sentido de que se han o
que tienen la oportunidad de desarrollar
su mente no de tener una mentalidad de
crecimiento de éxito no la mentalidad de
crecimiento se logra trabajando duro no
teniendo expectativas altas teniendo
resiliencia no que es algo muy difícil
en nuestros alumnos de lograrlo a veces
se quedan atorados
en a
en esto no en el que ellos ven sus
fracasos en sus logros en sus pocos
logros tantos se quedan atorados en esto
y definitivamente hay que cambiarles
este enfoque
y yo creo que es importante que los
alumnos entiendan que cuando tienen una
mentalidad de crecimiento pueden
aprender lo que sea cuando sea a la edad
que sea no es la vida no nosotros como
profesores seguimos aprendiendo seguimos
capacitándonos ahora con la tecnología
tenemos un reto enorme y yo creo que
esto es muy importante no porque cuando
tienes una mentalidad de crecimiento
realmente aunque las cosas nos cuesten y
lo sabemos no que tenemos grandes retos
como maestros pero sabemos que también
podemos aprender lo que sea no cuando
nos enfocamos cuando intentamos cuando
fracasamos pero lo volvemos a hacer
finalmente logramos el éxito entonces
necesitamos desarrollar estrategias
correctas para lograr podemos promover
la mentalidad de crecimiento premiando
como como lo hemos hablado no en esta
presentación a los estudiantes cuando
luchan por entender algo por lograr algo
y la mentalidad de crecimiento ignora
que ciertas personas son talentosas
naturalmente claro
todos tenemos ciertos talentos no hay
hay alumnos que nacen con una habilidad
para dibujar maravilloso a otros para
tocar piano y esas definitivamente son
reconocidas pero no quiere decir que
otros alumnos no la puedan también
desarrollarnos con trabajo con esfuerzo
con práctica etcétera tu cerebro no
puede crecer para mejorar en algo en lo
que no eras bueno antes
qué debemos hacer como docentes para
promover la mentalidad de crecimiento de
nuestros alumnos definitivamente algo
que nos puede ayudar muchísimo es
asignar a las actividades semanales de
mentalidad de crecimiento que se
encuentran en sus clases
es muy fácil asignar el contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento compartan su
experiencia es también usted es alguien
comentó ahorita las historias de vida y
eso es muy importante y lo volvemos a
cualquier recalcar acá compartan su
experiencia personal no las veces que
ustedes también han fallado no en un
principio y como perseveraron para ser
exitosos yo siempre les contaba a mis
alumnos que a mí en un principio con era
chica no me gustan las matemáticas
sentía que era pésima en matemáticas no
sentía que no se me daba etcétera hasta
que en secundaria y hasta secundaria
conocí a un maestro que de verdad fue mi
sol
no me iluminó mejor saque de repente me
cambió mi perspectiva de la materia me
encantó la materia
y en lugar de los cinco ejercicios de
tarea o los que tuviera hacia el doble
porque le encontré el gusto porque me di
cuenta que podía y eso fue labor de un
profesor
y eso cuando nosotros compartimos esta
experiencia con ellos ellos se
identifican diciendo yo también lo puedo
lograr es cambiar esta esta mentalidad
y bueno
mentalidad crecimiento tiene un
contenido como como les decía muy
específico para nuestros alumnos de
primaria o bien para nuestros alumnos de
secundaria y bachillerato es básicamente
este el contenido son varias actividades
entonces sí es importante que las
empezamos a asignar ya para que podamos
no cubrir con todas las actividades y
como asigno estas actividades voy a
entrar aquí a la plataforma directamente
para enseñarles cómo puedo asignar estas
estas actividades y aquí estoy yo dentro
de la plataforma digamos me voy a ir a
mi panel de tutor
ok y recuerden aquellos maestros que no
se han registrado todavía en campeonato
que no están participando es todavía
momento sigan abiertas a los re abiertos
los registros en tren entre maestros de
verdad que es una actividad increíble
registren se recuerden que para cada
clase tiene que tener un mínimo de 10
alumnos y bueno como así nuestras
actividades ustedes abren una clase voy
a abrir cualquier clase que yo tengo
aquí en mía ok voy a actualizar porque
tengo un alumno nuevo ahí y pongo las
asignó me voy a ir
ok me voy a ir para atrás voy a asignar
este lo que fue esta y como las asigno
me voy a contenido no ya que un
contenido si yo hago clic en contenido
aquí aparecen mi mental el crecimiento
qué pasa si yo no la tengo voy a citar
otro grupo en donde vamos a exponer en
este entonces yo digo que el contenido
yo en este curso estoy dando tercero de
secundaria área aritmética pre álgebra y
geometría básica éstas son los cursos
digamos que yo tengo asignados para esta
clase qué pasa si yo quiero asignar
mentalidad de crecimiento acuérdense que
siempre les de configuración o aquí
mismo en editar cursos ya sean editar
cursos o en configuración yo le hago
clic y acuérdense que cuando yo creo en
la clase puedo asignar tantos cursos
como yo quiera porque yo puedo estar
dando primero de secundaria pero a lo
mejor algo de segundo de secundaria o
pre algebra hay fundamentos de álgebra
etcétera cuando se abre aquí
no todos los cursos que yo tengo para
los dos esos me voy acá abajo y aquí
dice mentalidad de crecimiento y le hago
clic y le digo guardar
automáticamente cuando yo estoy en mi
clase si hago clic aquí en el curso que
yo estoy asignando aquí están las
actividades ya de mentalidad de
crecimiento hago clic en la mentalidad
del crecimiento y ahí se abre ya mis mis
actividades no y yo puedo decir ok
tengo introducción de contenido de
mentalidad crecimiento que esto sería
para todos actividades de primaria y
secundaria actividades de bachillerato
entonces si yo hago clic en y aquí en
introducción de contenido de mentalidad
de crecimiento puedo hacer clic en la
primera y decir consejos de perth para
los profesores esto viene siendo para mí
sin visión general del plan de estudios
y visión de entonces esta parte también
es muy importante para nosotros como
profesores y aquí ya bueno actividad
número uno para primaria y secundaria
cuando yo la quiero asignar recuerden
que es igual que asignar contenido yo
hago clic en la actividad
ok hago clic en en en cualquier
actividad que yo quiero asignar y
automáticamente se enciende el botón de
asignar y yo asignó esa actividad es
igual que asignar mis tres recursos
semanales no tú yo desde aquí voy a
asignar cuál es la actividad que quiero
que mis alumnos hagan entonces no aquí
puedo tener ok son tres actividades
dentro de esta entonces las lajas signo
igual para asignar las lo que voy a
hacer es seleccionar una fecha de
entrega a qué grupo le estoy asignando
si automáticamente a qué clase a que a
todos mis alumnos cuál es la fecha
límite la hora a la que quiero que lo
que ya esté lista que la entregué y la
así es así de sencillo entonces ustedes
ya están familiarizados con la
plataforma únicamente desde contenido a
la hora de seleccionar su curso
o lo pueden editar y agregarlas
mentalidad las actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento
gracias edith martínez nos encantará en
la siguiente sesión escuchar tus
comentarios tus experiencias con las
actividades la mentalidad de crecimiento
la maestra lilia estrada las actividades
de mentalidad de crecimiento las aseguró
de manera que las hacemos en conjunto
para comentar acerca del contenido les
resulta muy divertido interesante que
volar qué buen consejo qué buena
sugerencia gracias maestra estrada es
otra manera de hacerlo m me encanta
porque además nuevamente no estamos
promoviendo la colaboración la
comunicación y otras habilidades
el maestro carrillo imparto la
asignatura de macroeconomía excelente a
lo mejor aquí puede asignar también las
actividades de bachillerato
bienvenido conalep ticomán
saludos también desde desde méjico para
veracruz y gracias con la ley mexicalli
por estar presentes alguna duda de cómo
asignar el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento es muy importante que me
comentan aquí si si quieren que lo
repita no lo volvemos a enseñar pero es
muy importante que sepan cómo encontrar
estas actividades dónde encontrarlas y
cómo asignar las no porque en la medida
que ustedes lo tengan claro no les va a
ser muy sencillo asignar las entonces
aquí a través del chat por favor díganme
si quieren que lo repitamos y lo esté
con mucho gusto lo volvemos a revisar
para que les quede muy claro cómo dónde
encontrar estas actividades y cómo
asignar las
aquí en la presentación van a poder
encontrar
no esté unas diapositivas con este
procedimiento no de cómo hacerlo
nuevamente recuerden entrar a contenido
y desde contenido a la hora que ustedes
seleccionan
su curso no el curso que van a dar sn es
con esa clase ya sea rosa álgebra
trigonometría geometría primer semestre
h irato tercero secundaria etcétera
desde ahí mismo si se van hasta abajo si
se desplazan hasta abajo ahí dice
economía finanzas computación y están
ahí las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento ok
ahí las seleccionamos
y una vez que nosotros estamos listos
para asignar el contenido en esta
flechita podemos seleccionar las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
y una vez que las seleccionamos
recuerden que ahí ya entramos
dependiendo seamos maestros de
secundaria o de bachillerato ahí vamos a
seleccionar a qué contenido queda
acceder y al igual que con el contenido
normal
nosotros vamos a asignar al salón de
clases a los alumnos a todos sus alumnos
recuerda que aquí es importante
y queda listo entonces
cuáles son las redes sociales para
compartir avances de campeonato podemos
compartir en la en
twitter en twitter es muy importante
usar twitter yo creo que para mí es de
las redes sociales como docente que en
donde más tiene más alcance tenemos no
recuerden utilizar el hashtag del
campeonato
así ya está campeonato pueden también
postear la canaca de mí no
khan academy seguir incluso a khan
academy a en facebook hay una hay una
página de khan academy en español que
está increíble constantemente están
subiendo vídeos están subiendo mucha
información
entonces en facebook les aconsejo seguir
a khan academy en español y ahí mismo
pueden ustedes postear también con el
hashtag
en la misma página de que khan academy
en español postearlo en con el hashtag
khan academy campeonato perdón y poner
sus experiencias sus comentarios
suban fotos tomen fotos hay vídeos ya en
lo que se han creado en brasil en
estados unidos etcétera de los alumnos
celebrando no de su larga salvando sus
logros emocionados porque llegaron a su
nivel con su mismo celular tomen el
vídeo en el momento en que lo no es el
tablero del progreso muestra que los
niveles los alumnos llegaron al nivel
lograron su objetivo la alegría de sus
alumnos tomen un pequeño vídeo suban a
las redes de verdad no hay nada más
lindo tanto para ellos como para el
resto de nosotros no como docentes ver a
nuestros alumnos celebrando nuestro
también es muy motivador hasta para
nosotros entonces utilicen esas redes no
básicamente es twitter y facebook las
que se están
utilizando y recuerda que bueno al
principio nadie es bueno en nada todo
todo lo aprendemos a través de la
práctica a través de no darnos por
vencidos así aprendimos a caminar hasta
aprendimos a hablar hasta aprendimos
muchas cosas no entonces
es importante que nuestros alumnos
entiendan esto que la práctica hace al
maestro y si no se han registrado
regístrese ahora pueden entrar el
campeonato punto khan academy punto org
para más información siempre son
bienvenidos en cualquier momento pueden
registrarse
y
eduardo tomás dice desde mi punto de
vista está excelente la plataforma solo
que falta que se adecue a los programas
oficiales de cada asignatura por ejemplo
en los temas de álgebra del mst y ese no
es tan acorde tiene mucha razón profesor
constantemente la plataforma está
trabajando créanme en adaptarse de la
mejor valor a manera no solamente a
méxico sino también a otras plataformas
de habla hispana de otras lenguas
entonces definitivamente no hay un gran
trabajo todavía por lograr pero
constantemente están agregando
materiales etcétera entonces utilizamos
ahorita de la mejor manera los recursos
que tenemos y yo estoy segura no que
poco a poco se irán agregando nuevos
recursos en nuevos temas de nuevos temas
de manera que nosotros podamos
utilizarlos también de una mejor manera
dolores javier para motivar a mis
alumnos cada semana hago corte y les
pego sus avances en el salón y al
porcentaje más alto le doy un 10% en su
evaluación final y eso les motiva mucho
es una excelente manera no también
reconócelo a través de las
calificaciones para nuestros alumnos son
importantes definitivamente no hoy el
darles a la mejor como premio un 10%
etcétera asignar un porcentaje de la
calificación final al trabajo en khan
academy me parece una manera excelente
de motivarlos gracias maestra por
compartir con nosotros
compartan no nuevamente aquí con
nosotros tú si se comparte con nosotros
tus historias de mentalidad de
crecimiento tus historias también de
logro dentro del campeonato usen el
hashtag campeonato 2018 en cualquier red
social que tengan ya sea
twitter ya sea facebook
utilicen el hashtag campeonato 2018 y
suban suban vídeos suban fotos compartan
con nosotros no también consejos de cómo
están motivando a sus alumnos
sugerencias experiencias que realmente
nos va a dar mucho gusto celebrar con
ustedes también maestros sus logros y
sus éxitos les voy a pedir a todos como
último favor ya estamos terminando que
entren a este enlace si ustedes ya
tienen la presentación en su en su
[Música]
ahorita en su dispositivo con que hagan
clic en el enlace entran si no lo tienen
ahorita les pido de verdad tomen una
foto y den si no les cuesta más de dos
minutos les prometo entren a este enlace
y por favor este complete en esta
evaluación no para nosotros es súper
importante la retroalimentación el que
nos den o no su opinión sobre estas
capacitaciones estos entrenamientos
porque definitivamente nuestro objetivo
es cada día ser mejores y poder
realmente cubrir sus necesidades y
ayudarlos para que puedan lograr también
ustedes a su vez sus objetivos y él lo
va a dejar aquí unos minutitos para que
puedan entrar o en su caso tomar una
foto no nada
una foto con su celular y puedan entrar
después
mientras tanto ari coronado nos comenta
que los alumnos se dan cuenta de su
avance en el salón de clases al momento
de que estoy explicando un tema nuevo y
lo reconocen porque lo vieron encantó
esto los motiva a seguir con la
plataforma definitivamente es cierto no
es muy cierto no los alumnos además van
dando en su cuenta que no es tan difícil
no que cuando ya entienden algo cuando
ya lo practicaron definitivamente es
algo muy motivador
y bueno por mi parte es todo les
agradezco enormemente de verdad su
compromiso su esfuerzo su participación
en esta capacitación en esta en este
entrenamiento compartan con nosotros
entren a las redes y no se olviden por
favor de regalarnos dos minutitos para
completar esa evaluación nuevamente
muchas gracias que tengan una excelente
semana a todos ustedes un abrazo
ha de ser me perdonen que me preguntan
por favor puedes repetir donde subir la
foto que piden puedes subirla a twitter
con el hashtag campeonato 2018
puedes subirla a facebook la página
sigan todos la página voy a entrar al
facebook para que vean la página d
de khan academy en español